i want to stress that this is going to
be whatever happens
a difficult year for for travel there
will be hassle there will be
delays i'm afraid because the priority
has got to be
to keep the country safe and to stop the
virus coming back in
so no guarantees on an exemption from
quarantine from travelers who are double
jabbed
we're looking at it but i want to stress
that the emphasis is going to be on
making sure that we can protect the
country from the virus coming back in
what we're doing the single most
important thing for
the economy and indeed paying for the
recovery
is to ensure that we continue cautiously
but irreversibly to unlock and get our
economy
moving again that is the the priority of
the government
and uh we're working very hard on that
at the moment
it it's it still looks to me as though
july the 19th is a terminus point
and you can see what's happening already
we're
seeing uh employment up i've seen jobs
up we're seeing
uh vacancies up
uh we've got a lot of demand now and we
want to get things moving
as fast as we possibly can but in a
sustainable way
i think almost 60 percent of adults in
this country
uh have now had or been offered two jabs
so one of those vaccinated
countries in the in the world
but look at the the numbers of of delta
uh the delta variant it is sadly going
up still
it's going up by about 30 a week in
cases
uh hospitalizations up by roughly the
same amount and
so sadly icu emissions into intensive
care
so we've got to be cautious but we'll be
we'll be following the data the whole
time i think
you can never exclude that there will be
some new disease
some new horror that we simply haven't
uh
budgeted for or accounted for but
looking at
where we are looking at the efficacy of
the um
the vaccines against all variants that
we can currently see
so alpha delta the the lot of them
kappa um there's uh i think it's looking
good for july the 19th to be that
terminus point
i think what the scientists are saying
is that you know things like flu will
come back
uh this winter we may have a a rough
winter
for all sorts of reasons and obviously
there are big pressures
on the nhs all the more reason uh to
reduce the number of covid cases now uh
give the nhs the breathing space it
needs
to get on with dealing with all those
other pressures and we're certainly
going to be putting in
the investment to make sure that they
can